what's up guys bang bang Bitcoins having
a monster start to the year it's up 44
in 2023 which is the fastest start that
it's had in any year since 2013. now one
of the key data points is that Bitcoin
broke over 25 000 over the last week
that means that Bitcoin has fully
recovered from the price drawdown due to
the FTX collapse seeing Bitcoin come all
the way back to the price pre FTX
collapse is a great sign that Bitcoin
doesn't care it shook off all that
nonsense and Bitcoin just simply
continues to do exactly what it was
designed to do now one other interesting
data point that is worth paying
attention to is 73 of all Bitcoin in
circulation right now is being held by
long-term holders these are people that
do not plan to sell they continue to
Simply dollar cost average into the
asset and hold it for the long term the
more and more that the Bitcoin in
circulation is held by these long-term
holders the more illiquid the market and
when you have an illiquid market and any
increase in demand it usually continues
to lead to price increases we have seen
this play out time and time again when
it comes to the Bitcoin market and as I
watch that long-term holder Supply
continue to tick upwards it only tells
me that there will be upwards volatility
on the horizon at some point now on top
of that bitcoin's hash rate hitting
another all-time high this past week
that means that Bitcoin continues to be
more secure than ever before as we watch
data points like Bitcoin moving into
long-term holders hands and hash rate
hitting all-time highs you can talk all
you want about the FED interest rates
FTX being blown up regulatory pressure
and many other stories but ultimately
the underlying fundamentals continue to
be incredibly strong for the
decentralized digital asset and my
belief is that those who understand
what's happening outside of price
outside of all the nonsense stories and
simply continues to look at the market
structure and look at hash rate likely
will have a better view of what will
occur in the future we have seen this
story time and time again in bitcoin's
lifetime regardless of if it is during a
bull or a bear Market watching these
underlying fundamentals can go ahead and
give you confidence or pause depending
on how they look right now everything
looks great it continues to be
incredibly strong I'm cautiously
optimistic about the outlook for 2023
and Bitcoin just produces block after
block after block of transactions and it
doesn't care at all what else is
happening in the world I hope you
enjoyed this week's update and I'll see
everyone next week